Haley Joel what's going on and good to
see you
what's the hullabaloo oh you didn't have
his headphones on Jim wanted to play a
sound byte to try to start interviews on
the right note okay but he got we got
excited about himself I just like to hit
the button well I know you do you got
buttons in front of you right there
begging to be now that a lot of
attentions been drawn to it you don't
want to hit the button again okay so Sam
from Glengarry Glen Ross
well welcome man thanks thanks we're
just talking about first night before
you came in your you doing this Bob Ted
Bundy movie and Bundy had this
reputation of being like this kind of
like this guy who was like of all the
serial killers charming charming and
handsome and people forget what a brutal
piece of [ __ ] he was yeah and you can
really tell in the view video interviews
there that are available with him just
the manipulation is going on all the
time I think just one of the most
depressing things I've ever seen is when
like Jim Dobson is interviewing him
going like it was the pornography right
Ted like they're both just using each
other trying to find an excuse means and
it's just yeah it's just so dirty and
bad yeah so Zac Efron is a nice guy
who's a lot better-looking than Ted
Bundy so we had to they had to put some
some ugly teeth in his mouth and
everything because when people said like
Oh Ted Bundy was really handsome and
charismatic it's like I don't really see
it yeah compared to John Wayne Gacy fine
painter positive aspects to them too he
met the president's wife one time and oh
one quarter yeah yeah Secret Service got
a little chewing out for that I imagine
well he was a little we use like a local
I guess Democrat or something and yeah
cago and the he coast cue is like a
parade Rotary Club or something like
that or the Key Club or something like
that well photos that was our producer
earlier in Diamond Dallas HS Johnny
Dallas Page chopped
yeah and that was earlier today it's
fine just back to the chest
so what's this movie about it covers the
period after his first arrest and his
multiple escapes from prison while he
continued to try and exert influence on
his wives lives even from prison and I
play a sort of a composite character who
was a friend of Lily Collins's character
at the University medical office where
she works and is like you got to stop
taking his calls from prison like he's a
bad guy and that sort of stuff did she
believe that he was ever they when they
arrested he was driving a VW and he had
a wasn't it like no passenger seat or
something there was wrong yeah he
couldn't have been more obvious yeah
when they pull yeah and he had like a
fake police officer's uniform I don't
normally have a passenger so I took the
seat out I'm a singing telegram and tape
and lots of room yeah man do you uh do
you have to get yourself out of it like
when you stopped a movie like that I
mean I guess you didn't have to play Ted
bunny so you didn't have to go quite as
deep into the serial killer whirl but
still I mean to be a part of it you have
to kind of not read about serial killers
for a while after it's it's really hard
because I I don't think of myself as
someone who particularly enjoys true
crime things and everything but I still
consume a lot of that sort of stuff and
with cereal and and actually some of the
movies that are director Jo Berlin door
did he covered the West Memphis Three
trial oh so he's had an incredible
career as a documentarian to one of the
greatest out there and it is great yeah
oh my god and just incredible stuff on
the other side of it when the hysteria
is you know targets innocent people it's
it's really really crazy there are
things on Wikipedia I wish I had not
written read I wish I had not done read
I just want to find the person who said
that Coldplay is my favorite band it's
funny that's [ __ ] Gillette commercial
there's alerts when it's like this page
was edited by someone in the House of
Representatives you're like oh what did
they change yeah hey I want to ask you
to officer you're doing a comedy called
the devil has a name did you get to do
seem to Martin Sheen and alpha man yeah
I did not Alfred
but I had a lot with Martin Sheen and
with David Strathairn with Edie Edie
Alma's and Kate Bosworth it's an
incredible cast and that's based on a
true story about an oil company that was
contaminating water making it
radioactive in the Central Valley where
everything is grown in Kelvin that was
Martin changed my favorite human beings
yeah he's really I played golf with him
at some charity events before he's just
a fantastic guy yeah yeah I imagine the
epochal time ago yes now Martin Sheen
was not as pleasant you know thanks oh
yeah I would imagine that too I'm glad
that they ugly table Zac Efron because
the first thing I thought of when we
were talking about the Ted Bundy movie
that you're also doing is that if Ted
Bundy were alive today like he probably
pretty psyched that Zac Efron was
playing him like if they found out they
were to enjoy that run that's great yeah
I forget it's weird like even Timothy
McVeigh who is it I think ADX Florence
before he was executed he had access to
movies and things and it's like and was
commenting to his biographer or some
journalist before he was executed about
movies he liked and didn't it's like you
see I'm weird to think about that being
a user section of Rotten Tomatoes like
this one did not work for me to watch
movies it seems weird because there's so
many other things that could probably be
considered violations of the universal
human rights code or whatever but it's
like but you can get those VHS is still
I like I was watching escape from
Dannemora Ben Stiller's that's great
yeah but late and and Ben Stiller said
he kept really true to the story like
that was important to him and they were
showing the prisoners in that prison
with personal TVs in their cells yeah
which I was like I had no idea that
stuff like lights would go out it's like
time for everybody to go to bed or
whatever and the prisoners who had those
privileges had little personal TVs that
I think it makes it easy for the guards
I've heard to like if they're calmer or
if they have a reason to get that stuff
then it makes life a little bit easier
for the people who are in prison yeah
like you're less likely there's nothing
to get we're no way to work out and get
out your aggression and need the guards
a price much dangerous yeah
maybe that stuff is good it helps keep
those guys yeah definitely superb is you
get these two movies and then of course
future man that's right yeah the big
deal is for me the Sun and on Hulu
that's right just saw it like saw the ad
on a screen in Times Square which is
always kind of a crazy feeling but it's
a terrific season we're to almost 200
years in the future now I am a
holographic AI projection of my former
self from the 21st century and I'm
trying to offload humanity to colonize
Mars tomorrow yeah
so like real life yeah they take
something that's so high concept and
then don't take it tremendously
seriously yes just make it like super
high concept an idea and then make a
whole show about what a goof the whole
thing and the petty concerns because
like my character is an all-powerful
supercomputer but I'm still obsessed
with this one girl that I met for one
day and I've been trying to clone Eliza
coupe and it's sort of wrestling with
very pedestrian concerns while I'm sort
of deciding the future of humanity yeah
but that's the way we all would be right
it is I don't know if you saw the movie
the favorite this year like which is a
very funny movie but it's also kind of a
horror movie because it's these
incredibly petty immature people
deciding you know whether certain armies
invade France and stuff like that and
it's just like it's really scary yeah so
when the when the fire wouldn't win Hulu
earlier this week did you hear what they
did with the fire fest doc I saw that
well the doc to know that Netflix was
gonna do it that's why were you are you
rooting for the home team now you're
like holy [ __ ] who just came and like
completely made Netflix look like a fool
my shows on Hulu I'm on the winning team
I did I forget what in my one of the
football games got boring over the
weekend and in our in my like sports
group texts and my friends from high
school I was like future man season two
streaming on Hulu paid post but I it's
it just seems like an ethical question
because they were working with some of
those guys who had been advertising the
festival who clearly knew that it was
gonna be a danger disaster months ago
yeah so I don't know I'll see how it
plays out yeah it's crazy documentary
when the Talking Heads are like you're
like oh you're just as bad as the guy
who went to prison like everyone is
terrible like right right yeah the
further deep you go in you're like wait
they're all blaming this one guy but you
are
there too even the bartender that was on
the island he was like and when they
showed me like he was a master like
businessman from the day that he was
selling broken crayons to kids like I
think it was an obvious grift from the
beginning like one look at this guy and
know to stay away they said all right
the picture of the cheese sandwich has
become synonymous with everything fire
fest was and I just love like the the
villas so part of the problem that they
had was that they realized that first of
all they didn't have the island picked
out before they started selling tickets
so they start selling tickets right and
they build up all this the height
there's the cheese sandwich they build
up all this hype for fire fest and after
they start selling tickets they're like
[ __ ] we gotta go island shopping which
is usually even for the richest of the
rich a process that can take a couple of
years how much time before the four
months yeah
so they find this island that's really
just like it's it looks like a parking
lot a dump zone of a Sandals island yes
sandals and you could [ __ ] you could
have Google Maps did before you bought a
quarter million dollar ticket to go oh
this is just a conference how much
there were luxury packages for yacht
trips and things like that there were
250,000 dollars and I think they just
took that money I don't know if
everybody got their money back for that
bring their dog what they did was they
were like they were selling G a ticket
general admission tickets how much were
those a thousand dollars and they sold
to many so they just had went on the
website and said these are sold out the
only things you could buy now are the
villas which were going for $20,000 and
so people were so hyped up about this
thing that they start all started buying
the villas so now we're in this position
where I'll [ __ ] we don't have any villas
so they got FEMA tents and that's what
you see all those white tents those are
just FEMA disaster relief towns and that
was the villa
they just set them up and all these
people that paid for villas they get
there on a school bus and then a guy
tells him go pick a tent there
first-come first-serve
and there's a nice inside don't get it
chair mattresses Kroon about I mean it's
it's disgrace remember the email that
the one guy sends like micromanaging the
30-second ad video and he's like this
music and I feel like Hans Zimmer it
needs to be like the glory soundtrack
but dialed back 30% odd time signatures
table z'
Tico drums assets are like yeah three
page thing for like the music for a
little one their little island video
however no details about the actual
festival has ever figured out 0 the only
musician that was there was ja Rule been
to prison for tax fraud like everyone in
charge of it had already been in prison
protect wait there's also all these
bands didn't show up none of them none
of them yeah not one
so was uh people just run the beach for
no reason no no no no it's that's what I
must correct you yeah the beach was five
miles away from their location they were
not on the beach yeah it was not Beach
property and by like a concrete wash
with no fence and Rio lighting it's like
if you fell off that you would die right
extremely hazardous the big obstacles no
fences up also there was a torrential
downpour when it started just to add
insult to injury but were they well
prepared for that they were not they
were not unfortunately the FEMA many of
the FEMA tents were blown over at one
point he lies to this venture
capitalists that he has like a million
Facebook shares and yeah you can do it
so the guy puts in eight hundred
thousand dollars and he sits back and
goes let's go jet skiing documentary
shows that the guy who's organizing this
whole thing he told the venture
capitalist he had several million
invested in Facebook so we're good to go
he had about he had between one and two
thousand dollars in Facebook's is this
guy's in jail right he is in jail right
now he's serving six years oh good and
once he gets out he will be doing this
exact same thing again because when he
was out on bail he started using the
same email list from the festival to
scam people again he tried to do a VIP
ticket scam while he was out on bail he
was selling tickets to the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show which you cannot buy
tickets for which guy is he
his name is that right right there yeah
Billy McFarlane Billy McFarlane
yeah
Netflix didn't get him is because he
wanted to get paid for being a
documentary and Hulu goes yeah I mean if
we can like throw this guy under the bus
I'll pay for him he does not look good
in those interviews I have you have
never seen you gotta watch this watch it
tonight Jim I will because you've never
seen a guy bite his lip in a documentary
more time his bottom lip had to be
chewed and raw by the time he was done
and he's sitting there and ja Rule has
this amazing moment where they're
showing him trying to pitch this
business and because first Billy and ja
rule got together to pitch a credit card
which was also a scam but ja Rule is on
Fox News and the woman's interviewing
him actually yeah we have let's listen
to ja Rule on fox news we have this clip
and by the way you can watch this
documentary on Hulu the same place you
can see future male privacy trust me
when I tell you especially if it's
snowing near you and you're snowed in
it's gonna be a great weekend yeah but
this is this is ja rule pitching a
credit card we only need to listen to
the first 30 seconds just listen to jaws
pitch on credit card for Millennials the
man himself joins me now along with
Billy McFarlane the founder and CEO of
Magnus's gentlemen thanks for joining us
Charles you know so many celebrities
become Ranger rules for something or
other why'd you choose this you know
it's a very unique situation whenever
you can marry the affluent with the less
fortunate you get the birth child which
is called but you know when you when you
marry those two worlds together you get
something very special where is the
affluent where is the less fortunate in
this because this is go ahead okay
because we speak to the let me give any
he's talking about any more dues the
less fortunate it's like a luxury credit
card and the kids like I also misspelled
Magne says but whatever like yeah he
said he said I miss I think I misspelled
Meg leases because everybody kept saying
Magnus's cuz it's with an eye instead of
an E but he goes but whatever yeah this
credit card do well but I didn't do too
well yeah it only made but they used is
still available unfortunately not
he bought a sheet of metal from China
and like pressed his credit card down on
it it's like I made a credit cooker it's
it I mean he literally like what he's
explaining the birth of this credit card
the birth is not in the idea of the
function for it or the service that he
would provide it's in the physical I
figured out how we could make a physical
car and then how do I make money off
this metal car the guy with him looks
genuine though yeah you talking about
Billy looks very genuine trust right
that's Billy McFarlane Billy McFarlane
would go on to serve yes years in jail
for wire abroad and yeah I can't wait to
see his next venture because you know
he'll be right back at right back yeah
and here's the beauty of it so really
even the fire festival even if it had
been if it had gone over perfect even
that was a scam to really get a mailing
list together to launch this app call
fire and the idea of the app was it was
kind of like cameo except instead of
like paying people to say dumb [ __ ] you
could pay people to do dumb [ __ ] like
you could it was it was booking
celebrities right like you would bid if
Coldplay would be on the app and you
would say I'm gonna put $10,000 if
you'll come play my bar mitzvah and then
Coldplay would be on their vert end of
the app and they'd say either no or yes
that's the function of this app right so
fire fest is a total disaster and the
guy goes to jail ja Rule somehow stays
out of jail for fire fest and launches
an app that provides the identical
service the fire was supposed to once
and try to figure out how to do a new
festival I've never seen anybody fail as
much as in in so many different genres
as ja Rule and still survive I just rat
could rear-ended his business career as
a joke and he's still just like the man
right do you think he's what brewing his
rap crew 50 so it was a 50 cent did he
lose that fight unfortunately in that
rivalry
50 cent did come out victorious he was
victorious yeah yeah and in the world
versus fire festival of fire app ja rule
also ended up on the loose again I
wonder how much they paid him have they
said how much we paid him question no
they didn't but Hulu expressly in the
dot called him a liar like you are a
liar yeah they must have said it goes in
the DA he goes he goes if I'm lying tell
me one thing I'm lying about yeah and
then they do a music montage of all the
things he lied about I loved the one
quote that sort of like sums up the era
to he's like you know it had to be a
pretty brilliant idea to fail so big
sounds good that's a great meme like
yeah but it's not true it's like the
bigger the lie the more they'll believe
it yeah that's also not really
apparently he has Netflix for 250 250
thousand dollars you know this whole we
don't pay people for shut up you want
the guy in your show pay him but as it
turns out the documentary the Netflix
had is being produced by these guys [ __ ]
Gerry who are a marketing company that
we're the marketing company behind and
as you're watching it's like clearly all
these people knew exactly how this was
gonna go and they kept it going it just
makes my brain hurt when they go through
it's like when we were the geniuses that
figured out if everybody just posted an
orange square it was a genius social
media like takeover yeah that was what
they were paid millions to do you're not
I got all these models to post an orange
square right we're genius yeah we have a
new idea for you we're gonna do a green
square this is great though and Jim once
you watch it watch it tonight cuz we'll
talk about it tomorrow maybe we'll do a
deep dive into it they mark Connie is
the same font that is hilarious
isn't it great yeah we really [ __ ] him
up on this one on them maybe I didn't
know that Netflix had one planned yeah
right Jim they put it out unannounced on
a Monday when they it was announced that
Netflix was coming out with it on Friday
oh that's bad luck
bad timing oh my god
oh ah poor Netflix boys right do you
ever I was thinking about you last night
this is watching you know their next
thing thank you Jim they're promoting
this movie glass like crazy and it just
occurred to me I was like do you sit
there and you go em night if you're
gonna bring all these universes together
you can't give me the couple bucks a
jump and go like the B plot in that
night right like to Bruce Willis's in
the same reality that would be that
would break the the world I think yeah
that would really [ __ ] it up he's very
confused you just showed up and you're
like doctor this is what you're doing
yeah well it's like on Entourage like
some people had played minor roles in
the early seasons then had become famous
on their own and then appeared as
themselves later and it's like this is a
like a looped universe right I can't do
this anymore
do you see Bruce at all it's been a
while but he's he is called over the
years
I know his daughters were really nice
and icy night from time to time too I
saw him in a charity event like last
year or something but yeah they're
they're good guys we have good memories
together yeah Morgan how long did you
step out of acting for I came here in
2006 to study experimental theater at
NYU and I was here to like 2011 not
going back to LA at all and had a dream
that I could live here all the time but
everything casts and works in LA so I'm
splitting between the coasts at this
point I see you don't want to make sure
ya sell the place here yeah yeah and was
that much part of that because you were
like I just want to if I'm gonna be in
this world I need to step out of it so I
can actually go back into it it really
and it especially at that point in my
life because la I think can be a kind of
a like a soul killing place at that
point in your life if you're in the
industry and everything and I know
plenty of people who lived there and did
fine and had wholesome experiences but I
really loved being here and having
friends that weren't in the
entertainment industry and just sort of
having the anonymity in this city that
it somehow provides even though it's one
of the most populated city in America
yeah I I like I live here but whenever I
go out there I'm like why don't I live
here so pleasant it's warmer it's more
it is lovely
26 degrees here I'm like what a [ __ ]
dope I am if you lived out there you
just be depressed because you'd be like
I'm in LA I'm gonna start booking stuff
and you wouldn't that's not true like
I'm really working hard I know you've
been really plugging away you should see
me I've been in the mirror really doing
it yeah I do I pretend that I have the
people in the movies like Jim how did
you end up finding that you're your
enemy that was in the forest and he was
locked he was he was trapped in there
for so long what did you do
oh I said you know the story with that
right like not the character was written
as a cocaine addict and then they cut
that out so he's just screaming for no
apparent reason he's over the top yeah
but he's not though so they but he had
already started shooting scenes where
he's like hey how did that whole subplot
that that was part of what broke up
their marriage so problems yeah and they
just removed it from and then Al Pacino
is stuck basically doing that for the
rest of his career they're like no we
want coke down like that I like that
tune they cut out all homosexual
references but they just had Leon show
up in a role what do you do yeah that's
that's a big thing to take out because
it looks like he's just overdoing it
you're like what are you doing theater
acting for in a movie whatever the hell
yeah what's that why he's out doing that
it's a good actor right here take the
take his own TV out of the house when
she's cheating on him or something like
that's a really kind of psycho scene
yeah like why would you do that if
you're I don't know I guess he must be
really mad it's the rage that's making
its makin crimes gets it really excited
oh my god well his little lips yeah
adorable little lifts so take him up and
hug him yeah I do love a little I think
I was probably okay with his height at
this point yeah that like you know he's
out he's on stilts as far as I'm fitter
he's been out when attenuates success
tiny feet when do people start realizing
that you were a good comic actor I don't
know I got really lucky and right out of
college did a miniseries called the
spoils of Babylon with a Will Ferrell
and Kristen Wiig Wow that community
people is super cool and a lot working
with that you ever see Kristen Wiig on
the Joe Schmo show no you remember the
Joe Schmo show what was that there was a
reality show where the one guy everybody
was fake except for one guy brilliant
idea to turn into like something kind of
interesting were they they were pranking
him but then they sort of started to
like him or something is that that's yes
yes yes yeah so like the first see every
other season was terrible because it
didn't work but the first season worked
perfectly because the guy was so dopey
why didn't it work after that people
were on people figured it out and they
would have to change the show halfway
just but Kristen Wiig played a
psychiatrist on this show to Joe Schmo
show Matt Kennedy Gould was the first
Joe Schmo I was addicted to it I've
watched it many times had to claw my god
that looks great and yeah but like Matt
Kennedy Gould was such a likeable kind
of as regular a guy as you could ever
find he delivered pizzas for a living he
was just a simple dude and everybody
kind of fell in love with him but then
at the end of the show even the guy who
was supposed to be his best friend
he was like I'm cast to be his best
friend so I'm gonna go become his best
friend they all had to be like no this
is all fake and he's like yeah my name
is Greg you know what years I probably
Leggero was in there right no she was on
one of the was in a second okay I think
the first one was 2001 2003 is that
right okay do that throughout and it was
the early 2000s
ran for ten years I'm sure those later
seasons were yeah yeah and I don't know
that they were able to pump out a season
every single year when you say it ran
for ten years I believe there's three
seasons over the course that yeah but
yeah I was addicted to the first season
I had to get the watches because I mean
if you can find it I don't know where it
is anymore nobody talks about it it's
got it somewhere but it's the best
reality show ever because it's it it
worked
do you have see if you can yes what is
going on so this is the moment when he
finds out that the whole thing is is a
ruse and that everybody but I mean it
was so like Schmo they hired a guide to
basically be puck yeah
from the real world and his name was
like hawk or something like that or
hutch hutch was his name and he was like
I'm hutch and like I'm the guy like puts
his fingers in
Pedro's peanut butter you know I was
like it was it was so stereotypical like
cast every reality show guy but poor
Matt Kennedy Gold
he just didn't see it it looks bright he
does have that vacant stare and they
tried it looks crazy so what they tried
to do it what they tried to do and it
didn't like he ended up having really
hard feelings about it because what they
tried to do was they made it so that he
didn't win the reality show so he didn't
win the million dollars or whatever
right so he lost but they were like oh
good news this was all fake and you win
and he was like he did with money right
so he's just like it's just his emotions
are [ __ ] you know bananas off the
walls because they gave him the money
that's good and they said like you win
you're the big winner even though you
thought it were lives are alive but
everything here was a lie and this guy
is not really your friend and this girl
doesn't really have a crush on you and
it's all been raised we made it all up
but they go but but Matt we did it for
you
like what they're all having a crush
it's not a good thing to do to a person
no that sounds like look like the creepy
stuff they do at Guantanamo or they'd
like throw a guy a birthday party just
to mess with this thing like that's like
almost worse than waterboarding like
yeah whatever just psychos four days
later it's another birthday but why I
don't understand and why is this
happening at 3 o'clock in the morning
we're torturing then they all of a
sudden were like it's your birthday it's
akin to the person who probably has no
concept of American birthday parties or
the Sun just to be crazy yeah just yeah
yeah [ __ ] II they were lately yeah
yeah do they give them a birthday food
propagate me hey hey yeah
[Laughter]